[Music]
so if you want to find some news on amc
you just go on yahoo finance you tap amc
here
and then you're gonna have the news flow
that is very good on this website
and the first thing you see guys is this
so it's charlie mungler
so who is like uh the associate of
warren buffett
who are managing one of the biggest
hedge fund in the world
and let's see what they say it's
actually conglomerate it's not really
hedge fund
well i don't participate at all and i
think the world would be better off
without them
i think this can so he said i think the
world would be better off without them
he's talking about
the crazy speculators that you can find
on reddit or everywhere
i'm sorry like i shouldn't call them
crazy because actually
they're buying undervalued stock so this
is good but once you have the short
squeeze and they keep buying it then
this is craziness and this is not
healthy for the market
let's see what he thinks of it the crazy
speculation
an enterprise is not even found or
picked out yet
is a sign of
irritating bubbles so he's talking about
all this
flows the signals that it gives to this
guy right he knows what he's talking
about
it's a signal of an early bubble and i
agree
but to me the bubble has just started
guys we are at the beginning of it
and if i do some uh updates on the s p
500 on this deck
you're gonna actually be very surprised
by the level i would give you you know
i'm talking about 100 200 in the coming
year or two years i think that this
is what's gonna happen the investment
banking provision
will sell shares one and say can be sold
you heard it
the investment banking profession will
sell [ __ ] as long as [ __ ] can be sold
charlie munger so what does it mean guys
it means that as long as the short
interest is close to
you know below 30 40 hedge funds are
gonna go
and short the stock if they feel
this is overvalued so this is a good
question to be honest i don't have
uh the skills to make a deep fundamental
analysis and tell you yes or not if it's
overvalued or not
but hedge funds are going to do it asset
managers are going to do it for now
they're buying
it so probably the answer is no not at
this levels
but they're probably going to sell it
higher so just
to tell you that don't expect a short
squeeze happening on amc
this is going to be a normal bullish
pace which is
healthy and good and i'm convinced we
are going to go to
43 but not in a matter of few days
if we do it means that the hedge funds
uh
you know decided not to short it which
actually the answer just
was given to you by uh charlie mangler
they're gonna sell it
if they can one more thing if you check
the news
so why central amc i'm gonna do central
blackberry
very soon amc blackberry and all the red
stocks so today guys this is very
interesting
so you probably knew that i'm going to
go through this article but very quickly
you probably heard
of the fact that during the gme uh bull
run
and the amc that followed uh robin hood
actually forbid
new positions to be created if you were
long you could sell but if you were not
long gme
or amc you could not buy it the reason
behind
is to actually you know uh try to
get control on what was happening during
the squeeze but the real reason behind
is the
margin requirements guys if like the
margin requirements are not big enough
then you know this broker which is robin
hood can
lose money so they didn't want this to
happen and now they increased
so robin hood subsequently raised
several billion dollars
from investors to better comply with
those requirements so margin
requirements
should tr trading volume increase once
again so right now they are prepared
so well well ready traders appear to be
gearing up to test robinhood newly
strengthened capital reserves
the game is different robin hood people
put more money so
robin hood feels more comfortable to
allow them keep training
so this is the second round that is
starting now guys let's see
where it goes with the training platform
likely to be
reluctant to impose new buying
restrictions so there should not be
due to the black flash it faced last
time around it would be interesting to
see how
any potential short squeezes will play
out with no interference from birmingham
i agree i agree but once again there's
not going to be a short squeeze on the
show on the stock
that has only 12 percent of short
interest once again
12.8 guys this data is correct anyone
that doesn't agree with that
put it on the comments and let's see
let's find out i'm gonna answer to you
and if you are right just please give me
some good information
but please check at the daily volume
first before telling me
something that is nonsense so let's just
conclude on the
technicals so like i said the next level
is for me
43.9 and you're gonna have some
resistance level
all the way up so the next one is
actually so this one is overcome
1250 guys it's a strong resistance level
let me show you this
on the daily time frame you can see it
quite clearly so how do you find these
levels guys very basic you try to find
areas where you had the most support and
resistance and the closer it
is in time so the most recent it is the
better it is
so here you can see i have some highs
all right so
it gives me a hint it might be a
resistance
level now i check if in the past i had
some support yes
yes yes and here it was a fake breakout
i'm downside
but you know we had some good reactions
here
so 12 50 guys is the next resistance
level
so if you are not long and you want to
buy it guys as i said
in the video i did yesterday you can
wait for something like this
so it might take few weeks guys but you
have time you know
something like this might happen i don't
know you are not long here
don't buy here guys this would be a
mistake i mean you know a trading
mistake of course
you can be lucky but this is not how we
trade you wait for a re-test and you buy
at 750 but you with a tight stop loss
around seven
and then you wait for the new resistance
to be broken
and same thing guys here you can take
profit you can buy here take profit by
here you know this is how we trade guys
you need to find support
resistance areas and go on the shorter
time frame on the hourly it worked well
on amc and
set up your trades so guys that's it for
me
i hope you enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys